vendredi dernier une professeure de
français a illustré son cours sur les
métaP les métamorphoses d'Ovid avec la
présentation d'un tableau de guissp
César il ne s'agissait donc ni plus ni
moins d'une manière de lier deuxart la
peinture et la littérature depuis
pourtant cette professeur et l'ensemble
de l'équipe éducative ont demandé à
bénéficier de leur droit de retrait en
cause des élèves se sont insurgés contre
des ressenti comme raciste accusation
qu'ils ont pourtant depuis reconnu comme
étant mensongère trop mal trop tard le
mal était fait il ne s'agit pas d'un
simple fait divers et je crois que cette
cette situation est l'illustration d'un
problème plus profond dans nos écoles
celle de la remise en question de notre
principe de laïcité monsieur le ministre
ce sont bien vos mots que je fais mien
aujourd'hui à l'école française on ne
conteste pas l'autorité on la respecte
l'école française on ne conteste pas la
laïcité on la respecte ce sont des
propos que nous devrions tous
saluer
pardon notre pays héritier des lumières
et de l'universalisme ne peut se laisser
enfermer dans de telles attaques nous
devons défendre notre principe de
laïcité qui je le rappel impose le
respect de toutes les croyances
l'égalité de tous les citoyens devant la
lo de religion et la garantie par la
République du du libre exercice des
cultes le principe de la laïcité est un
pilier de notre société pour nos enfants
l'école est un lieu de son approtissage
et ils doivent accepter d'y construire
leur esprit critique mais ne doivent pas
rejeter ce qu'ils apprennent au nom de
leur religion quelle qu'elle soit
réaffirmer réaffirmons ensemble notre
soutien à l'ensemble des professeurs
menacés et remercionsles pour le courage
de leur engagement merci beaucoup
monsieur le député la parole est à
Gabriel Attal ministre de la l'éducation
nationale et de la
jeunesse merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député
balanan il faut en revenir à l'essentiel
le rôle de l'école française c'est de
former des
républicains et notre école l'école
française elle a des racines et dans ces
racines il y a la laïcité il y a
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
il y a l'autorité de l'enseignant et je
le dis monsieur le
député même si certains même si certains
cherchent à provoquer ces racines ou à
déraciner notre école ces racines elles
sont solides elles sont porté chaque
jour par des centaines de milliers
d'enseignants qui forment des
républicains qui démocratisent le savoir
au service de notre pays et de notre
République je le redis ici devant vous
comme je l'ai dit hier aux enseignants
d'ous je me suis rendu au collège
Jacques carartier jamais je n'accepterai
à l'école de la République qu'on refuse
de regarder un tableau qu'on se bouche
les oreilles en cours de musique qu'on
s'en prennent à l'autorité d'un
enseignant vous le savez monsieur le
député j'ai placé mon action sous le
saut de l'efficacité moi je ne prends
pas des positions je prends des
décisions et je les fait appliquer c'est
pour cela que sous l'autorité de la
première ministre et du Président j'ai
décidé d'interdire le port de laaba et
du camis à l'école et que j'ai fait
respecter cette
interdiction c'est pour cela que j'ai
décidé de sanctionner les élèves qui ont
contesté le moment d'hommage à la
mémoire de Samuel Patti et de Dominique
Bernard et que ses élèves ont été
sanctionnés c'est pour cela monsieur le
député que j'ai dit dès hier que les
élèves responsables de cette situation à
Isou seraient sanctionnés et je vous
annonce que ce matin une procédure
disciplinaire a été ouverte à l'endroit
des trois élèves à l'origine de cette
situation oui monsieur le député c'est
un combat c'est un combat qui est
difficile mais je sais avec cette
majorité que nous gagnerons ce combat
pour l'école de la République et pour
notre
pays merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre